each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
yes okay so I wanted to introduce power
Obion Tennessee to you so I'm first of
all I'm Roland from the incubation group
and power law as we've been doing this
PhD with orbitz front again at
university of texas at austin on
different linear algebra libraries and
powder is currently you're doing is
postdoc at Duke yes that's it thank you
thank you for having me here so today
I'm going to talk about than Selena
Rajab ram libraries and I will target i
will show you two different types of
parallelism so the point being that when
we are now we have these multi-core
architectures and it's really not clear
even for a pretty standard application
like dense linear algebra it's really
not clear yet how to extract the
parallelism out extract performance out
of these architectures so i will show
you a couple of different approaches and
so let me give you what normally is it's
the outline of a talk in high
performance computing when introducing
when talking about libraries so you know
the objective is always high performance
and then normally there are some slides
presenting some experimental evidence
that you know attaining high performance
it's difficult it's important and then
there are some slides some graphs
showing that it's important to have many
different algorithmic variants many
different algorithms probably we also
need many different implementations so
what we need we need automation that's
that's pretty much the standard outline
so what I'm going to do instead is do
all of the above actually yes I'm going
to follow the same and then i'm going to
show you that when we target multi-core
it's not even clear what how to what
type of parallelism to targets so it's
not even clear
how to exploit this parallelism so 3 the
final point is ok that we need
automation now I want to make a point
right from the very beginning that when
i talk about automation I do not refer
to optimization as in a compiler
optimization so I do not refer to I have
a routine or a piece of code and I'm
going to try to shuffle or rearrange it
and optimize it when I talk about
automation here I talk about ways of
generating different algorithms
generating starting from a mathematical
expression expression I want to generate
different routines different algorithms
then each individual algorithm can be
further optimized with compilers
techniques but that's not what I am
going to talk about today please don't
be scared about the 57th lights it's
it's not going to be a super long
talking so I open 45 or 50 minutes we're
going to be out of here but please feel
free to interrupt so this is the real
outline I'm going to start with brief
introduction we went past that gonna
show actually evidence so I'm going to
go through some interesting performance
graphs then I'm going to talk about
flame it's the project that tackles all
of the above I'm going to show you how
we do we deal with automation number 5
is what is under underneath these
automatic system that i will present
number six is a totally different
completely different way of approaching
parallelism and then i'm going to draw
some conclusions okay so let's start
from some easy example the traske
factorization of a matrix a consists of
computing made a triangular matrix L
such that ll transpose equals a a is a
symmetric and positive definite so we
have a problem size along the x-axis and
performance along the y-axis the eye of
the batter these problem size here
indicates that these matrices are dense
matrices
and these are pretty gigantic ones for
dense matrices it's up to 15,000 and I'm
going to push it even further later on
so what I have here is a i used my
automated system for creating three
different algorithms again these three
different algorithms are have different
performance signature as you can see of
different stability stability analysis
properties so they are entirely
different in grey I indicate la pack so
obviously one of the three variants the
the one in blue with with the dots with
the circles clearly what we generated is
exactly what la pack as implemented so
what I'm displaying here is performance
on on a sequential architecture so this
is a single core and what I'm proving
here is that the variant that a lay back
lay back is the de facto standard for
dancing linear algebra operations it's
the library it was implemented in the
early 90s 91 92 and it was targeting
sequential computers as well as a
sequential architecture as well as
shared memory architectures so the point
that I'm trying to make here is that the
variant that they selected was almost
the best one was just a tiny bit
suboptimal but really not not a big
difference now what if we execute the
exact same three algorithms this time on
a shared memory architectures so now the
problem size goes much higher up to
40,000 by 40,000 there are the same
three variants and in a pack is once
again a second best again it's not you
it's not second by a large margin so
what they did in them in creating this
library they have to make a decision so
I'm sure they were aware of all of them
all of the three variants they decided
that they lay back
for every operation would include only
one variant only one algorithm so they
chose pretty much a good compromise
between the case the sequential and the
parallel case over here parallelism is
obtained just by invoking multi-threaded
blast in case you don't know blast
stands for basic linear algebra
subroutines so linear algebra as dense
linear algebra as this beautiful
property that as is built on on top of
very standard layers the bottommost
layers is is made of is constituted by
these blasts so these are very basic
routines matrix-matrix multiplication
being the most important ones and every
other linear algebra operation is always
expressed in terms of these operations
so over here parallelism is obtained
simply by using a multi-threaded blast
so the algorithms here are exactly the
same as in the sequential code but
parallelism is obtained thanks to the
blast if you look at the top variant
over here it's the one with the
triangles so variant number three if you
paid attention is actually the variant
that performs the worst in the in the
sequential case and by the way this is
all the other way around the to the
squares as are the best ones in the
sequential word oh look at that they are
by far the worst in the parallel world
okay let me show you another example
probably even more meaningful what
happens if i run my parallel Jaleski
this time the matrix instead of being
stored in the upper half in the upper
triangular part of the the matrix
remember that i'm the input matrix is a
symmetric so i will never use the full
dance matrix at the full storage i
belong in store either the lower half
for the upper half so if i use the lower
f and i use lay back here is the
performance you get
and we're out of the story if I stick to
one a single algorithm you changed sheet
you change things just the tiny little
bit and you can have performance going
you know yes inspiration for myself
what's worse insights the access it's
out the map the memory is accessed over
over here you including huge penalties
because the memory instead of being
accessed by columns it's basically
almost accessed by rows so just this is
Ali's a start sorry a is starting the
upper triangular part over here a is
starting the lower triangular part if
you only stick to one valued things can
go really wrong okay let's change
operation now this is a the inversion of
a triangular matrix there is a reason
why I'm choosing these simple operations
I will get to that later on over here I
was able to generate four different
operation for different algorithms for
solving the problem again in a pack
implements one of these four and again
it's a sort of a good compromise between
the sequential and the parallel word
most importantly r is that problem
dimension ok this is times ten to the
third so this is 40,000 by 40,000 most
importantly r is to notice that for
small problems one variant is the best
and then this valiant doesn't really
perform as good at all for medium to
very large problems another variant is
best which is not what an apex selected
these benetton down here not only it's
pretty bad in terms of performance it
sorts of horrible in terms of stability
this is actually this variant is
unstable which means that if we add a
exact arithmetic yes it would compute
the exact solution since we do not have
exact arithmetic we have round off
errors this guy actually doesn't
converge doesn't compute the right
solution so
the morale of the stories we really need
a lot of different variants which it
really need a lot of different
algorithms there is clearly not Wiener
44 not single winner in every possible
case so flame is the project that tries
and tackle this problem how to generate
how to create I performance libraries
for dense linear algebra flame stands
for former linear algebra method
environment it's not a library by itself
it's a set of theories and tools to
generate libraries it's a collaboration
of a number of people robert van de
ganas the leader learning chinese my
successor is neo PhD student that is
responsible for the second part of the
talk for the implementation of the
second approach as we should you go to I
think some of you are familiar with his
name is the Guru that writes super I
performance low-level super
high-performance blast he ends tune and
tunes or all of these all of these
libraries and then we have a number of
collaborators in Europe and at IBM oh
well responsible for the library it's a
field on Z is the guy you really put all
the pieces together so I brought an
overview of the project as I pointed out
we always start with a description of a
linear algebra operation so we do not
start with the routine we start with
really with the mathematical expression
from the expression we have a mechanical
system that is pretty much my PhD
dissertation that generates algorithms
this box here is the same as the
mechanical system but it is performed by
hand so as a result we get to a family
of algorithms then we have a family of
AP is so that these algorithms can be
mapped to a range of different
architectures and situations so we have
an API for a sequential world we have a
capi fortune API metra Mathematica we
have an API for distributed
architectures API
for shred memory architectures and multi
cause there is some work in progress on
out of Koree p is separate portion of
the project deals with the analysis of
these algorithms i'll point out later
out the performances the pedic analysis
of these algorithms is crucial actually
pointed out i really showed you evidence
that the stability analysis of stability
properties of these algorithms are
important because some of the algorithms
that we generate should not even be
timed that because they do not compute
the right number so a few fee a few key
features of the project I think really
the most important feature is that we
were able to identify the right level of
abstraction at which to work and at
which to code dance linear algebra
algorithms thanks to it was because we
identified this level of abstraction
that everything else was possible so we
actually shoot for former correctness so
we we do not claim our algorithms to be
correct because of testing but because
of the formal proof and in fact we use
the formal proof to build the algorithms
so we have a proof of correctness first
and we we build the algorithm in such a
way that is correct we have a mechanical
system to generate both algorithms and
code we generate not one algorithm by
the family of algorithms so that we can
attain I performance on a range of
situations stability analysis so this is
the last chapter of my dissertation we
have a way of well we are introducing a
new way of establishing properties of
these algorithms and this group is
pretty much dancing their algebra some
pretty much the entire blass a good
portion of a laid back but not entirely
and then at the entire rack c library
which is a number of operations for
control fearing okay abstraction as i
said it's the most important thing so
that's where we
start from this is a representation of
the Trull ascii factorization is input
alice output is Alice lower triangular I
indicate al to be the chillax key factor
of a matrix a like this now everything
everything lays on on answering this
question can i express a matrix L the
solution not only I wanna I'm asking
myself can i express the different
portions of the solution matrix as a
function of different portions of the
input matrix if I can do this then I
will show you that I can have automation
going so in order to answer the question
I simply plug these these partition
matrix into the expression like this and
now I say okay this is what needs two
old simplify and we get down to this
expression this expression is a
recursive definition of the Trull ascii
factorization let me spend a few words
on what this means so first of all we
call it partition matrix expression it
means it expresses the solution or it
expresses different parts of the
solutions as a function of different
parts of the input it says that the top
left quadrant the top left portion of
the solution matrix contains a look at
this the CH Alaska factorization of the
top left part of the input function
which is which is great ok then it also
says that the bottom left portion of the
ink of the solution corresponds to this
guy over here and the bottom right
portion quadrant of the solution
corresponds to this if you look at this
just by looking at this definition it's
recursive definition one can think of a
recursive algorithm for computing that
should ask factorization so let's say
that we have completed the algorithm up
to this portion then what what we think
about doing oh look at us we could
repetition now we have four quadrants
like the record
definition so maybe i can compute shall
ask of this quadrant i can update this
guy can update this guy and then I can
move on and say okay I'm done I'm down
here and now I simply have to compute at
Alaska fertilization of the remaining
part so it's pretty simple that you keep
doing that it's recursive definition
okay so this is how I explain it on on
the board when you go and code this up
this is a see implement answer this is a
matlab in print wait this is neither
these are oh yes DCC this is C and this
is mat lab for a block variant these
this code both of these codes don't look
anything at all like what i just
presented before it was very simple we
had everything on the board we had the
quadrants and four different parts of
the matrix and right here everything is
lost so this is exactly what we want to
avoid and this is how we code it instead
this is how we express the algorithm and
this is how we could it this is the
algorithm so let me explain step by step
up here I partition the matrix in two by
two and this is the corresponding matlab
function over here i say okay i'm done
up to this point now let me progress so
I repartition this bottom right quadrant
over here is our do it in MATLAB down
here I say okay now I'm done let's let's
move a 1-1 from the part of the matrix
that I have still have to operate on to
the part of the matrix that I am done
with and then this is the part of the
computation the part of the algorithm
where I'm perform computation so I will
always talk about algorithms and code at
this level of abstraction how do I get I
performance how do i how is it possible
to code at this level well we define
api's we define these functions
partition repetition continue so that I
I can repartition petition
matrices in different languages so once
i have that once you have the partition
matrix expression i told you this is the
amount of information that i need for
automating the generation of algorithms
why well first of all this operation
tells me what needs to be done I need to
perform at Alaska factorization in to
perform a triangular solve I need to
perform rank K update followed by
another of classy factorization so I
know what operations need to perform
also I see that there are dependencies
for instance I'll top left here is
updated by Lasky factorization and then
I'll top left appears on the right hand
side so clearly there is a dependency
there is another dependency I'll bottom
left is updated here and then is used on
the right hand side here so there is
another dependency so this expression
really tells me everything that I need
to know to create algorithms and in fact
from this expression I can identify
looping variants loop invariant in case
you don't know it's it's a predicate
it's especially important in computer
science it's a predicate that holds true
when you have a loop and it also true
before the loop is executed it holds
true at each iteration of the loop right
at the top of the iteration at the
bottom of decoration and it holds true
even when the loop is 0 is finished it's
completed if you can identify loop
invariant then you can build the
algorithm around it that satisfies it
normally it's the other way around the
loop invariant is used for proving
correctness of algorithms normally you
have an algorithm and someone scratches
is at really hard and then tries to
guess a loop invariant and then if the
loop invariant is true then goes ahead
and prove the correctness of the
algorithm we can do the other way around
we can state that the loop invariant
ahead of time and beat the algorithm
around it so what we say looking for any
for instance of the first expression we
know that we need to compute at Alaska
factorization and then a triangular
solve here and
anna is in rank K update here so i know
that i cannot compute everything at once
otherwise the algorithm will not be
otherwise there would not be a sequence
of steps so i need i need an iterative
loop begin so I'm I can ask the loop 2
satisfies these conditions so I can ask
the loop to compute the operation in
such a way that the top left quadrant
always contains the final solution
initially the top left quadrant will be
empty so there is nothing to be
satisfied then the top left quadrant
would be a tiny little block and what I
have to do is to fill it in with the
right solution and then I'm going to try
and expand the top left quadrant a
little by little until it's as big as
the whole matrix so if I have a loop
invariant I can cut it up in Mathematica
actually I can coat the pme up in
mathematical a partition matrix
expression and from that I can pass it
to my automatic system and my automated
system returns an algorithm the
algorithm says okay I'm going to use
this loop invariant so I'm going to
partition the matrix like this I'm going
to progress through the matrix like this
and like this and in order to satisfy
this loop invariant this is the
arithmetic operations that you need to
perform and also my system identifies
that there are dependencies in red and
so you heard it orders the operations in
such a way that the dependencies are
satisfied now since your arm there is
more than one loop invariant then my
system returns more than one algorithm
here is a different loop invariant and a
different algorithm okay I can do
something a little more challenging this
is a Lyapunov equation this is the
equation everything is a matrix here ax
and C are matrices and I want to compute
X this is the partition matrix
expression for that operation once a of
that my system returns an algorithm
funny thing here is that my system
identifies that Natalia have to saw
another lyapunov a expression of a
equation over here but there is also
this other symbol i use this symbol to
identify sylvester equation what is a
Sylvester equation it's this guy over
here it's a more general operation so
now if I really want to compute if I
really want to solve the Lyapunov
equation I also need the partition
matrix expression for this operation
over here because I have to compute
these as part of the the apple of
algorithm so i can type in that is a
partition matrix expression and my
system returns an algorithm for that in
fact it returns 14 algorithms for this
if I want code here it is a matlab code
and if I won't see this is the seat
again we have a API this is a way of
partitioning the matrix this is a way of
repartitioning continue and these are
calls these are actually not I had to
end called the blast goes to be honest
okay the scope I guess we can skip this
slide so very quickly I don't want to
bother you with details but very quickly
I want to go through a few ideas or a
few reasons why all of these works and
then I'm going to show you a different
approach to parallel ISM a different
type of parallelism so as I said we not
only we shoot for former correctness but
we actually exploit former correctness
so we start by identifying an operation
in terms of two predicates the
precondition and the postcondition the
precondition explain tells us what the
operands are like what the contents of
the variables are like at the beginning
of the computation so for instance if I
want to invert the matrix it says okay I
have a matrix of L of size that it's
lower triangular it contains something
and I call it something I'll had the
post condition tells me what the
variables need to contain at the end of
the computation so that the computation
is actually completed and
the it's pretty simple I 1l to contain
not he'll hat but the inverse of a lad
okay once i have the precondition in the
post condition i can try and build an
algorithm so that i can start the
algorithm in a in a condition where the
precondition is satisfied and hopefully
it cool it completes and completing a in
a condition when where the post
condition is satisfied so this is an
important point having correct
algorithms doesn't mean that they are
stable it it only means that if i add
exact arithmetic they would compute the
right solution unfortunately we do not
have exact arithmetic we always have
round off errors so on top of former
correctness when dealing with numerical
algorithms you also want a numerical
stability which means that the the the
roundoff errors are propagated not too
much a precise definition would involve
norms I don't want to bother you with
that but anyway we set up this worksheet
this worksheet resembles linear algebra
algorithm in the sense that is as an
initialization step that I called
partition and then it has a loop that
goes from three down to here as part of
the loop I have a loop guard and then I
repartition the matrix so I'm wanted
make some progress I have some
computational statements and then I have
a way of making progress and then what i
do i select one operation that i want to
solve say inversion of triangular system
i write down the partition matrix
expression from the partition matrix
expression i can identify looping
variants different looping variants i
select the loop invariant now i'm going
to go 100 miles an hour but that's okay
and i plug the loop invariant in all the
places in the algorithms where it needs
to be satisfied here here here here at
that point to do some magic
and I say okay I want the loop invariant
to be satisfied here here here and I
also want the algorithm to complete so I
partition and repartition the matrices
in such a way that I make progress at
each step that point I reacts press the
loop in variance in terms of these new
matrices and i end up with it these two
studies one states is what is sitting in
my matrix right now and these other
state is what needs to sit in the matrix
at the end of the computation I compare
and I establish what computation needs
to be performed at each stage and my
automated system does all of these
automatically so that you don't have to
look at these ugly formulas ever okay
now let's go to some performance graphs
that may be a little bit more
interesting gonna show performance for
the computation of the inverse of the
symmetric positive definite matrix why
is this important because it's used for
computing the gravity field of our
planet so it's also used in tomography
these are people in aerospace
engineering have these huge problems
even an improvement of three four five
percent for them was crucial because
they would allow that would allow them
to discard data more actually would
allow them to either run larger problems
or discard I have a quick turnaround on
their data so basically they acquire
data from two satellites and they have
to decide what columns or rows of the
matrix to discard and which new columns
or rows to add so the faster they can do
that the more accurate their computation
can be so this operation consists of
Alaska factorization or surprise that's
why I I talked about it and then it it's
normally implemented as a sequence of
three steps to ask you factorization
first triangular inverse second and then
a matrix-matrix multiplication a special
case of matrix-matrix multiplication
third okay we generated algorithms for
each of the three steps and then we
played around
with the combinations and we plotted the
results for the best two combinations
and you can see that we are somewhat
around ten percent better than la pack
what did we have to do really absolutely
nothing we just asked for chili Skeeter
angular inverse a matrix-matrix
multiplication we generated algorithms
and we time them so we development time
was next to zero and we were able to do
better than in a pack already now can we
do better than that until now everything
this was a parallel algorithm and until
now I didn't say a word about about
parallelism I simply exploited a
parallel blast the multi-threaded blast
so natural question is can we do better
than the parallel blast so can we create
parallel ISM ourselves so the answer is
obviously yes so let's take a look at
the first iteration over the cholesky
factorization we have a classy operation
up here then we have a triangular solve
year and then we have a rank K update
second iteration to Alaska triangular
solve rank K update ok well triangular
solve if i look at the matrix as a block
of matrices Jaleski ok once i'm done
with this Jaleski I i can actually
decompose this triangular solve in three
blocks so in three different triangular
salts so these can be three different
tasks to be executed the moment I
execute this first task I immediately
can go ahead and execute this rank K
update I don't have to wait for these
two tasks to complete likewise the
moment i'm done with this task i freed
these other two tasks for a gem
matrix-matrix multiplication and another
triangular so another rank k update so
an idea is to actually run the algorithm
not all not on the numbers but simply on
blocks and to create a list of tasks
that will need to be executed later on
like this but these tasks have
dependencies so it's not just matter of
decomposing the problem it's also a
matter of making sure that these tasks
are ordered and executed in the right
order remember after the first janeski
was performed than the second triangular
salts then the triangular salts can be
executed only when the triangular saw
one of the trend results can be executed
then this trick can be executed and so
on again so we need a dog the directed a
cyclic graph expressing the dependencies
once we have that we can actually
execute we can have four different
columns for different cores acquiring
tasks and executing tasks independently
so let me explain what I'm showing here
clearly there is only one initial tile
with agile a ski that's what needs to be
executed in order to break the
dependencies as soon as the first task
is executed by first column so one of
the course all the other cores can
acquire tasks independently and start
working now I am just showing tasks in
red black and blue representing the
three different stages I said that
normally the computation of the
covariance covariance matrix that is the
inversion of an SPD matrix is performing
the sequence of three steps to Alaska
first inversion second and then
matrix-matrix multiplication well it
turns out that if you break the
computation down into pieces into chunks
of work you don't really need to have
this a synchronization such a such a
rigid structure where you have to feel
complete Jaleski and then you have to
complete in order to have the triangular
solve to begin and then you have to
complete
resolve in order to have the circ to
begin you can actually just be this dag
with all the dependencies and let the
different processors the different
course acquired the tasks and then it
turns out that the tasks and so the
three operations are actually
interleaved so you see that there is
block before red time goes from top to
bottom clearly so at first all the tasks
executed come from CH Alaska but then we
have some black tasks and the black
tasks are associated to the second stage
of the operation so here we have
parallelization in two different ways
for one thing each operation is broken
down into tiles and the tiles are spread
over the multicores and circle different
stages of a big operations are
interleaved so that the the pipeline is
always filled okay this is these pretty
much summarizes what I just said so we
have a we have implemented a component a
new component I'll greet me component
which we call the analyzer what the
analyzer does is it looks at the
partition matrix expression it's always
the same expression that makes
automation and makes everything possible
it looks at that expression and it
breaks the computation down into pieces
not all it breaks the computation down
but it also builds dependencies among
these pieces and puts everything into a
big queue and then we implemented the
not a dispatcher we don't have a such a
an entity but what the multi course
perform basically is the implementation
of a dispatcher which is they were they
are sitting they look at this waiting
queue the global waiting queue and they
acquire tasks when the tasks are have no
dependencies as soon as they are done
executing a task they go back into the
queue and they free all the tasks that
were the
handing on on this task and then these
guys loop until the the queue is empty
how do we do this so this is a C code
for the SPD in verse in flame so we have
a partitioning where is it your
partitioning we have a loop
repartitioning we have class key
triangular shawl rank k update and then
we we move on this is the exact same but
on a matrix that is that doesn't contain
numbers but contains other matrices so
it's anarchical matrix and a march
through the matrix looking not at
numbers but looking at blocks of data
and then I include these tasks and then
I will execute a task can you see the
differences probably not so let me help
you the differences are in red so most
importantly is down here that I need to
execute something at the end of the
algorithm because remember the first
state the first pass through the
algorithm I really do not execute
anything I simply build and in queue
tasks over here I have a filet and over
here instead I have a flash flash means
that is anarchical matrix over here I
march through the matrix in blocks of
size B which is the block size over here
I don't march in terms of blocks I
simply look at the blocks one by one
these are the differences and of course
all of these can be done automatically
performance-wise not is the the range
here goes only up to 10,000 so I am
limiting myself to as molar matrices and
what these shows is that these are the
variants that I was plotting before that
were doing pretty good in fact one was
doing better than a lay back but over
here i have the variants that implement
the super matrix approach basically the
the variants that have explicit
tiling and you see that for smaller
problems they perform better than a
multi-threaded blast why it's pretty
simple actually the multi-threaded blast
as everything in that linear algebra is
almost everything in density nadja bra
is tuned for very large problem sizes
these the new approach the super matrix
approach do not have a very large
operant day it operates the super matrix
approach creates small tasks the idea is
to feel the multi-core as soon as
possible even when we have a small
problem or a large problem we want to
create small chunks of data that that
the the multi car can operate on and so
that's why the super matrix approach
behaves even better performs even better
than our than the multi-threaded blast
for smaller problem sizes then it
plateaus because clearly once the
pipelines are full it doesn't really
matter how many more tasks there are in
the pipeline's they will always operate
at a trait and that's the rate that it's
shown here on the other side when you
have a multi-threaded blast you really
rely on the performance of the
multi-threaded blast and you know that
the larger the matrix the better the
performance so eventually there is going
to be a crossover and then show you the
crossover later
we have sand you know variant 1 and beta
doesn't vary in three and over here you
are showing that by pipelining it well
actually all three variants please we
give you the same for comments it's not
just by pipelining well it's a it's a
good question the answer is that when I
break the computation down you have to
perform exactly the same arithmetic
computation if you look now I'm really
it's true that the algorithms are
different but now I'm breaking down the
algorithms and I'm looking at the unit
of computation block by block and that's
pretty much identical it might be in
different orders so there might be very
tiny differences but now if you look at
the list either the sequence of blocks
at the sequence of tasks they are
exactly the same for the trio should you
expect similar performance curve space
when you do ya know these are not the
same only if you only when you break
them down they are the same well when
you look at the operation itself it's
not the same at all say on one on one
side that you can have a triangular
solve on matrices of of a certain shape
when you decompose it down you have
triangular salts of squares on another
algorithm you may have a gem on matrices
of a completely different shape and and
the shape plays a huge role in a dense
linear algebra but when you you're super
matrix Williams it's not worries that
shape is not playing role in there be
cook all the same because the shape ear
plays a role over here what I've done is
I eliminate the shape I break everything
down to be a unit block a single block
so basically yes there are tiny little
difference is these blocks with then
without the pipelining basically like
what would you basically get if you just
pick the sheer remove that ship variants
out how much performance difference
would that actually give you as opposed
to base by adding the pipelining how can
you remove the shape it's just you
done for the for the super matrix
variance I think he's saying if you if
you partition the metric sub-blocks as
you will run you will execute seiko
sequentially right yeah I mean just a
sequential variant by removing that
particular factor if you say that the
fact of this we makes a big difference
with each ANSWER Answer the block size
factor that you're talking oh the block
size plays a crucial role because yeah
between the three variants and if it
doesn't make a difference in you go away
no no no the blocking factor doesn't
doesn't define it's not different in in
the three variants I say that the shape
of the matrices and the different
algorithms if you look at the algorithms
let me show you two different algorithms
let's see algorithm or an algorithm to
okay over here we have this is a rank K
up this is a triangular solve and this
is a troll asking if I show a different
algorithm I have a completely different
operations so if you but yeah that's
that's what makes the difference not the
blocking if you look at the operands of
these operations you'll see that the
shape of these operands is different
it's it's not a block in the blocking
exact always the same in fact well okay
okay let's talk about this later so I
got the point that performance of the
super matrix approach was better than
the multi-threaded approach for small
problem sizes here I want to show you
that there is no trick if I if I stored
them in if I asked for the lower
triangular version of class key remember
that's where you get a flat performance
down here with super matrix you get
nothing like that and this is plotting
larger problem sizes and you see the
super matrix plateaus
while flame while the multi-threaded
variants keep increasing in performance
this this is slide also shows that
depending on the blast that you use well
for one thing the crossover changes but
also it's interesting that same if you
use the go to blast then you see that
the super matrix sorry so let's compare
go to blast with m KL m KL is a blast
from Intel so if you compare the two on
super matrix you see that the MK i'll
blast attains a better performance on
the multi-threaded instead you see that
go tubeless attains quite a bit better
performance why that is the case because
m KL it's better tuned for smaller
problem sizes and that's exactly what
super matrix uses while ago too does a
amazing job for large matrices and
that's why the super the multi-threaded
blast that multi-threaded variant is on
top these is just to convince you that
having that having larger than sorry
that having a variety of algorithms is a
good thing over here I am running the
same algorithms but on a distributed
memory architecture and I'm showing that
just by combining the the good
algorithms together we were able to gain
a 22 even 30 actually 20 25 to up even
thirty percent performance with respect
to scale up scale a pack yeah I have a
processors and I have performance per
processor and so this was a really big
gain for the guys yeah I just based
engineering guys okay conclusions
incoming current yes we wanted to derive
we wanted to create high-performance
algorithms for algorithms and routines
for dense linear algebra i showed you
that automation was possible thanks to
the partition
six expressions we were able to automate
the creation the generation of
algorithms we were also able to automate
the breaking down the creation of tiles
so we not only attain the former
correctness we really use former
correctness to generate algorithms we
generate family of algorithms and I
showed you that we generate two types of
parallelism or at least we shoot for two
different types of parallelisms in for
both types have married for small
problems problem sizes the tiled
approach is a superior for large very
large problem sizes the multi-threaded
approach is a superior in the future
what we need to do is we would like to
have performance tools so that we do not
have to run all these algorithms to
identify which one is best in watch
scenario but we would like to be able to
predict performance so thank you yes yes
networking number theory my matrices are
likely to be module primed or over
finite fields anybody working on
generalizing this type of software to
work there let's see I think that I
think that when I will visit the
University of Washington someone gave me
a paper exactly on that I we are we have
never looked at that problem
specifically no I think someone right
here in Seattle they are well so I'm
sorry no yes so automation so basically
you want to so first partition the
problem then you'll find a group
environment right the partition is our
only one way to partition suppose you
have medical waste partition if you have
multiple ways that's right and you
should recursive on in that reference
you well yes I I skip that detail
normally in fact you need
more than one way of decomposing the
problem because what i showed you know
the examples I always showed you that we
traverse the matrix in one single way
from the top left down to the bottom
right that's actually not true in the
generally speaking you also need ways of
the composing the problem say from left
to right and from top to bottom so
you're absolutely right you need more
than one way of decomposing the problem
even further those that unparallel that
house how could you aunt bee sided to
say choose the tile how could the
parties in the comm say okay I true the
style yes that's also that sorts a good
question so over here I decided to break
the problem down into tiles what I do I
call Kazushi could go to up and I say a
kazoo she can tell me what do you
optimize your matrix-matrix
multiplication for he tells me 216 128
and I partition accordingly so that I
exploit the maximum performance out of
out of the blast yeah so you're super
matrix numbers are pretty pretty good
but I have not seen a single graph will
terms those numbers are different for
the different variants I mean we have
gathered he doesn't doesn't really
happen that much no they they really
over seems like 1,000,000,000 that you
basically you can do one variant and
basically by planet well yeah yeah
absolutely this is just for academia
it's just too this is just to prove a
point yes that that's for sure yes I
agree so you give results for cholesky
and super matrix you have implanted
other factorizations I assume yeah and
what so what properties
because choice p doesn't have a pivoting
yeah yeah yeahs building is a delicate
other fabrication algorithms do you see
the similar kinds of results are people
thing would break the decomposition down
entirely so for people think we have a
workaround which is a different safer al
you we have a different type of pivoting
if you really want to bring the real
pivoting in that's totally different
story yeah we have a look into that yet
and without the other father won't let
you see similar performance yes yes
obviously yes for small problem sizes
yes because basically what we we get we
feed the multi beasts the multi-core
beasts faster we are able to create
small chunks of data chunks of work that
they can tackle early earlier on and and
they stay the the beasts the multi
course they stay eating the whole time
so you compared to the multi-threaded al
impacts have you compete with the
multi-threaded factorization routines
and in here ah just the glass in emails
but the actual Jaleski factorization oh
I don't know why we have not done that I
assume they're not as good I don't know
I cannot answer that I'm not sure yes um
so you say that you you break up into
these blocks of the computation started
a bastard yeah um have you looked at say
um an approach where you would start out
with small block sizes so you can get
yes that's a that's already yes that's a
very clever idea we add that idea we
haven't implemented yet yes that yes
absolutely it's a little trickier than
that because i don't know if i should
get to this level of details
but when the planted threads are so when
the multicores acquire task they do not
acquire the task randomly we also assign
a weight to each task and the way to
depends on the an estimation of the cost
and you want larger costs larger weights
to be executed earlier on so what you're
doing it goes a little bit against what
you're suggesting goes against that
because you would create light blocks
earlier on you would create lightweight
tasks but yes we have thought of that we
have not implemented it yet yes so
because i read that the proposed of the
rubber except it so in fact this
approach basically i will fit to all of
them an ipad cuz the real king seems
like there's something i don't remember
this unresolved yeah yeah sorry no i
skipped it slide it's true now we cannot
cover the entire la pack here we go
anything that has to do with SPD and
with eigen I can values eigen vectors we
cannot do that there is a simple process
there is a simple reason for that these
operations do not have a pme partition
matrix expression in other words say if
you have a I donation familiar with
eigenvalues but it's not possible to say
all these eigen value or these set of
eigenvalues it's not possible to express
them in terms of a subset of the input
matrix each eigen value depends on each
entry of the input matrix you cannot
have a recursive definition so whenever
you do not have that recursive
definition which I call partition matrix
expression you cannot apply this
methodology
here